[Music]
hello everyone can you hear me is it
fine is okay cool again sorry for being
late it's not entirely my fault
I could have booked a train so that bit
was my fault but yes so the first thing
I'd like to ask you folks before I start
is normally I spend the first half in
order 45 minutes of this tutorial just
helping people set up their environment
because they can go back home and then
you know do their own text analysis
stuff now there's two things one thing
is the Internet is kind of iffy that's
the first bit the second bit is since
I'm also late to save time would you
want me to skip this part of actually
setting up all the environments I have
all the instructions I mean on the
github link which I suppose you should
have all got if you don't have it let me
know and I actually can't help you find
it because my internet isn't working but
we can somehow find it so do you want me
to spend this time in setting up the
environment and doing all that stuff
because honestly it would be really
useful for later but if you're not super
hard about that then we can just go
ahead with the fun stuff if you want to
then just a show of hands how many
people want to spend half an hour
setting up environments yay
no one okay cool this makes things easy
okay wonderful
though I do want to make it a point that
it's actually the reason I spend so much
time in all of my tutorials and setting
up this stuff for half an hour
I don't I don't I don't that's also why
but I suppose okay I'm still going to
continue talking is because the
environment which I suggester you know
ask people to use this right now the
state of the art in natural language
processing text analysis and
computational linguistics so it would be
really useful if you had this particular
stack on your personal computers you
will be able to find all these
requirements on my personal github page
which is my name Bhargav BHA or oh thank
you so it's on github and then it's
waiter like Darth Vader I was really
young when I made that and then go to
personal
personal and you should be able to find
notebooks text analysis tutorial and you
should be able to find
particularly notebook so is that okay
with everyone it would be really nice if
everyone was kind of on the github page
if they had the internet yeah
I'm sorry come on
Oh Suman can i zoom in okay I can there
we go
so I'm sorry everybody's everything okay
yeah okay a little more okay yeah it's
command tosses it no thank you
I not know that okay so it would be nice
if everyone is on the github page so you
would know what are tools we will be
using and there's a particular reason is
because most days if for you if you just
search up text analysis and python you
normally get an ml TK link and you have
a lot of examples with an OT k an all TK
is a Python library called natural
language toolkit I suppose and I'm gonna
be talking about how we don't want to
use that I really really do not want to
use an LT k it's old broken academic
code if you want to test something out
it's okay it's fine but if you really
want to do any cool funky stuff no I
know TK is not what you'll be doing it
has a bunch of different tools or you
can try out different things but it's
not really what we're interested in is
data science practitioners if you want
to learn a little bit yeah you can
google that stuff on your own but
another TK is the opposite of what we'll
be doing instead I'll be focusing on
something some things some libraries
which are more efficient at least
libraries which actual people are using
in production the main library which
I'll be talking about is called spacey
spacey is computational linguistics
library in particular and I'm it's think
there should be links later around here
or on my github page but Spacey's the
library which I will particularly want
to introduce and after that we'll be
using three Python libraries used a lot
in machine learning for text one is
Jennsen which is used for topic modeling
which is why it's called a topic
modeling tutorial tips and tricks and
topic modeling you will have
scikit-learn which i suppose most people
here everyone knows about and you have
kirius which is used for deep learning a
few things before actually
started this is not a tutorial we'll be
going in depth will be more to more
depth a breadth tutorial so we're just
going to kind of be exploring different
possible things you can do with text
rather than looking at one particular
method and going deep into that I used
to normally have a tutorial I used to
work specifically on topic modeling and
that tutorial is on the same directory
this one's on so after we're done with
this if you'd want you can go back and
check for more details on topic modeling
in particular and I've kind of littered
my entire library and I mean this entire
repository on github with a lot of
useful links and other notebooks and
things like this so do like start it and
like make sure you know where it is so
it's useful for you folks later yeah
okay so now we can get started
unfortunately I don't have this over
here so have to also be looking at that
which is kind of annoying yeah so what
we're gonna be doing is first what I
wanted to do was actually walk you also
through the data collection part of text
analysis which is also an important part
of it for example if you're scraping
data off the internet of Twitter because
it's a lot of fun because Donald Trump
treats so much and it's just fun to look
at what he's talking about and of course
there's reddit I spend way too much time
on reddit and it's it's really
interesting because you can there's a
lot of textual data which is structured
really well if you've been on reddit
it's a forum for question answering it's
kind of I mean there's lots of threads
and you can see who's replied to whom
and so on and so forth and this comes in
nice JSON files which you can download
so websites like this are particularly
useful for text analysis because it's
structured data with replies and
conversations I like reddit more than
Twitter for example because there's the
language is better depending on which
subreddit you're on but more or less
read it seems to be a more cohesive
sources a lot of online sources which
are very very interesting unfortunately
we will not be doing that because I
found out when I was actually figuring
out how to scrape data that's an hour
and a half on its own so we're gonna be
skipping the part where we're going to
be scraping data and going to when we're
actually having our data so once so if
you're going to be doing that that means
okay first I'm going to start with my
imports if anyone else it would be
really awesome if you all had this all
these libraries and a jupiter notebook
running so you could be pressing the
cells with me but if you don't then
you're just
be watching me press the cells which is
also fairly exciting and suppose
yeah and that's imports and they're
using we're using piano so Kira's runs
on both piano and tensorflow I think the
default here is piano for me at least
this isn't Python 3 this notebook and
yeah these are some other imports for
matplotlib the section on gathering
grader I've just written down some of
the things which I told you which is
about the whole Twitter collection part
and so this is the important part since
we're not going to be using data which
we collected online I'm going to be
using two data sets throughout this
tutorial which are already available on
some of the libraries we're going to be
using a lot of libraries do this for
example Kyra's has the IMDB sentiment
analysis data set pre-loaded Jensen has
the lis corpus which is just newspaper
articles over I think a year in
Australia and scikit-learn has the xx
and G data sets again newspaper articles
so a lot of machine learning libraries
have pre-processed kind of pre-processed
textual data sets on there I mean in
their code base so the first one which
we'll be using is the lis background
corpus this is a little bit of
background about this corpus it's I
think I believe 300 articles from the
years 2000 to 2001 by an Australian news
agency so the context is more Australian
but it's generic news and this is the
data set which will be first using to
kind of start and get a feel of what
we'll be doing before I actually get
into the media stuff are there any
questions in particular anything you
want to know if you please feel free to
stop me while I'm talking raise your
hand if you have any problem especially
with the code because I'm gonna try and
walk you through every single line of it
but please tell me if something is not
clear yeah okay cool so now I'm going to
be loading the data here this is just a
bunch of always stuff to make sure that
we're at the Jenson path to pick up our
data and now we're gonna start with the
cleaning part I'm gonna talk a little
bit here more about what I said before
which is about NLT Kay and Spacey
and also about cleaning data in general
I cannot I mean of course in any kind of
data analysis problem or you're gonna be
dealing with messy data that's that's
how things are and in some cases
cleaning or not cleaning it will make
big different in text analysis it makes
a really really big difference
especially depending on what kind of
task you want to do I'll give you an
example let's assume that you want to
generate text if you want to generate
text which is like you know just for
example if you want to mimic how
Shakespeare writes or something then
you're gonna want to not strip away any
parts of the original data because you
want to capture the way Shakespeare use
his articles used as nouns every single
bit of the way Shakespeare wrote is
relevant if you want to generate textual
data which is like what Shakespeare
wrote like but let's say instead you
want to do topic modeling which is a
technique where we find out the key
topics in a large body of text we won't
care about some words like the and and
these are called stop words normally in
natural language processing stop words
or words which don't add any particular
extra information to the corpus for
example like it three words I said
articles are usually stop words words
like same go here there these are all
stop words are not necessary so in your
results if you want to see stop words
for in the case of Shakespeare then you
wouldn't get rid of your stop words but
if you don't want to see stop words in
your final analysis yeah you're gonna be
wanting to get rid of them so my point
is cleaning data knowing what kind of
results to expect and knowing what you
want to see is really important before
we start in our first few examples we
will be getting rid of stop words
because we will be working on topic
modeling so I'm going to show you a
little bit about how we're going to be
doing this with Spacey a little bit more
about Spacey and why I particularly
really really enjoy using Spacey well
firstly so the way Spacey works is they
have what they call a pipeline now when
you pass text through this pipeline it
annotates the text when I use the word
annotate annotate prettier means to mark
or label it for example when you are
mark your classes like class
one-two-three that's also called
annotating but maybe a more so before
you pass your text into the pipeline
Spacey doesn't know what your classes
are anything what Spacey does know is
the English language if we're going to
be using the English language model a
Spacey also has German Italian Dutch
French and a couple more ones coming up
as well really active young community
doing a lot of fun stuff so there should
be more languages but we'll be focusing
on English and so what Spacey does in
its English language model is it starts
to annotate and tag your text it starts
with first tokenizing tokenizing here
means it's gonna break up for example if
it's I went to the bar it would break up
I went to the bar is five different
tours and usually it figures this out
using white spaces which is your spaces
between your words now Spacey is
intelligent it's not only using white
spaces it knows how to pick out
sentences how to pick out words and so
on and so forth it does most of the
stuff using a neural network and they
really fine trained these models also
when you download these models you have
to if the first choose which model you
want trained on what kind of data so now
you have your basic tokenizing but
Spacey does a lot more it also figures
out parts of speech like nouns and verbs
and so on and so forth and it goes one
step further it picks out something
called named entities named entities are
things like organizations for example go
data-driven is an entity PI data
Amsterdam is an entity Amsterdam is a
geopolitical unit then you have places
so it marks different things which are
for example an apple is not an entity
but the company Apple is an entity and
these are called named entities it also
picks out something called in sentence
structures when we parse a sentence we
gets weakened dependency parse it what
does this mean
actually you're gonna see an example
which would make things easier but you
get the gist of it Spacey does a lot of
really really cool computationally
linguistic intensive stuff in one
pipeline now apart from things like
parts of speech tag and your named
entities why is this interesting for
cleaning our text it also points out
what stop words are which word to stop
words which words or numbers which words
are punctuation this means when we're
creating a corpus
corpuses the data which we actually want
to create and give to our machine
learning algorithm when we're creating a
corpus we can get rid of numbers if we
don't think they're important we can get
rid of stop words we can get rid of
pretty much anything and everything we
want to and keep what we want to using
Spacey's pipelines which have now
annotated our text is that clear
because this is very very important this
is something which for example ltk does
not do in NL TK if you wanted all of
this you would have to write code which
removes stop words manually just like
you get a massive list of stop words you
check your list to whiff list if the
word is in stop word remove word from
list and so on and so forth I mean yeah
we can write the code but the whole
point is we don't want to waste time
writing this code which we write every
single time when we do text analysis
same with numbers you can of course have
a list of numbers and say get rid of
numbers but species really need because
it does all of this boring hard work for
you and it does it extremely easily in
fact in just this one line of code so
I've sown I do NLP is equal to space
heat load en en is the link to the
English model which I talked about
before which you would have had if it
should have downloaded if I came earlier
and when we do space C dot load we're
loading this English language model into
NLP which is our variable storing the
model and this is a pipeline so NLP now
is our pipeline the next cell Jupiter
cell so I include the cell over here to
give a small anecdote about natural
language processing in general so this
corpus like I mentioned before was a
corpus with newspaper articles yeah and
when I was trying to find my topic
models using using this pipeline the
word say and different forms of say like
saying said and so on they were not
counted as stop words but you can
imagine in a newspaper article there's
gonna be a lot of people saying say said
so on so forth so when I was getting my
topic modeling results I didn't really
need the word say in it and say just
kept coming up really really high in my
list so I manually added these words to
my list of stop words why do I mention
this is that in any I mean of course you
do this in every machine learning task
but particularly in text analysis you
sometimes expecting a certain kind of
result so sometimes you have to look at
the results and say Oh
this doesn't make sense go back and
restart our entire process until we get
results which we kind of want it to look
like this may seem counterintuitive but
then because of the fact that these are
more exploratory algorithms are going to
be looking at like they're going to make
you explore your text you know not
classify your cluster this is useful so
you should kind of run your results once
just look at your results and say okay I
don't want my results to look like this
and then make small changes to make sure
results look a little bit or make more
sense so I mean in this particular
example the words say was didn't have
any it wasn't supposed to lean my final
topic model so I've added this to my
list of stop words the way spacy
identify stop words is every lexeme
vaccine is just another it's a class in
spacy which stores the word and it
stores certain characteristics of words
so here we're forcing these words to be
stop words for this particular example
this small loop runs through it if you
want to add more words just add more
words to that list um now I talked about
running your text through your pipeline
yeah this particular cell you see over
here oh it's much easier if I look at
this one alright so this particular cell
over here is actually the cell doing
most of the heavy lifting in this one
line of code and it's gonna take some
time to run because it's not tiny but
this is 300 articles now doc contains I
mean after so text was our initial text
which we loaded from over here this is
our text and then we're running doc is
equal to NLP of text so we're passing
our text through our natural language
processing pipeline I talked about how
the moment we're doing this now spacy
has a lot of information about every
single word every single token in all
your documents so let's look at what
exactly doc so this is it this is every
single one of our documents it looks
exactly the way I mean it's unprocess
you're not gonna see any tags because
it's just plain Unicode text you can see
it's just basically our documents over
here but
what's happened under the hood is space
he has annotated every single one of the
tokens over there so hundreds of people
every single one of these tokens have
been annotated with lots of different
kind of information so now let's start
with yep Oh like punctuation marks and
numbers are also tokens I'm sorry I'm
just cleaning up there yeah yes yes and
like the way so you can actually chain
spaces tokenizer of how you want it to
make tokens for example you can see this
word like it says night long encounter
in southern Kashmir like night long
so normally Spacey breaks this in
tonight and then the something called
again the hyphen and long so you have
three different tokens but then you can
actually train space these tokenizer
telling that if you want a catch-all
hyphenated word just one token that's
possible as well so Spacey is kind of
flexible about the way it does this
because it's it trains it identifies
these tokens by using machine learning
algorithms again and some rules as well
you can modify these rules if you want
to for your particular task but normally
those will be three different tokens so
now I want to show you that you can you
can yeah most definitely that's the fun
part now isn't it we'll be getting there
in a small bit spoiler alert but yes so
what's gonna be happening here is the
previous example I showed you the entire
document being processed by the NLP
pipeline yeah now it's kind of difficult
for me to show you particular examples
so I'm gonna just use a smaller sentence
over here which is uh which is this so
I'm so you don't notice I'm doing pretty
much the exact same thing I mean double
party I did dark is equal to NOP of text
but I don't want to show you the entire
document being processed because it
takes time and I'm lazy so I'm instead
I'm gonna show you just the sent it's
gonna so basically whatever space he did
to the massive set of documents it also
is gonna do to the sentence is just
easier from you show you yeah so we're
gonna I'm gonna show you some of the
first things which space he does
and this particular part I mean just to
be pedantic this is called computational
linguistics because these are all
traditionally these are tall tasks we do
when we're studying linguistics and
since we're making a computer this
particular part is technically called
computational linguistics which is kind
of different from natural language
processing which is more statistical
machine learning kind of stuff but these
terms tend to overlap but just to be
correct I suppose and yeah we're gonna
start with paws tagging and what part
so paws tagging stands for part of
speech tagging yeah and you can actually
so of course in different languages you
have different kinds of parts of speech
and spacy has different language models
for different languages and even for the
same language you have for example an
English language model trained on
medical documents on you know particular
domains if you'd like but know what
parts of speech tend to stay the same
across I mean in the same language even
across different domains so parts of
speech at least in English are like noun
verb or proposition and so on and you're
going to now look at so how you do it
over here is for token in Scent which is
you know for every single token in my
sentence which has been processed by the
pipeline i'm going to be printing the
text the pass and the text so i'm gonna
just show you what this looks like
so over here you can see that tom so tom
proposition you know proper noun and
then n NP so here n in P stands for the
exact tag so even when you have you so
you have your broad parts of speech I
believe there's nine parts of speech in
English and correct me if I'm wrong here
I'm not a linguistics expert but I do
believe it's nine parts of speech and
then after that you can kind of focus in
on more on which particular tag it is in
that kind of part of speech so what you
can do over here is this is a super easy
way for you to just print out every
single part of speech of every single
word now why is this interesting or
relevant for example I did a small
experiment to find out what adjectives
were used to describe Harry in the Harry
Potter series the most in the entire
book which is really interesting because
I just had to so I got my sentences and
then I tried to find out in which
particular case is there an adjective
for Harry in that sentence a noun and
then I checked my list of adjectives and
then I just count them and I have all
the adjectives used to describe Harry
so you can see how this kind of
information depending on the task you
might want to accomplish could be kind
of useful you might want to make a topic
model which only has the words in all
these sentences in which case when
you're cleaning your corpus get rid of
anything which is in a word so for
example you would be doing if token dot
pause is equal to equal to worm included
in corpus you see so you can use this
kind of information in really cool ways
depending if you if you care about it
now in normal machine learning
statistical kind of problems we don't
care so much about the part of speech
but it's still interesting information
to have another thing to note is that
you can turn on or off different parts
of the space pipeline if my internet is
connected or showing you the different
components but so I do believe it's
tensor izing which is something which
they do for their internal making sure
it's in the right data structure then
it's tokenizing part of speech tagging
named entity recognition and then
dependency parsing and so on and so
forth there's five or six different
parts of their pipeline and each part
takes different times so if you only
want to know about stop word and someone
asked me a question about limit izing
you don't need the part of speech or the
NER types so if you're running some code
in production and you don't need this
you can turn them off I usually include
them because I think it's useful
information to have and it just takes a
couple of seconds more but this is just
to give you an example of the kind of
things you can do with Spacey's pipeline
will be now moving on to any art tagging
I talked about ners before any RS or it
needs sense for named entity recognition
and over here again so we so there's
different kinds over here there's only
one entity which is Tom so you don't
really have much I published a better
example and I'd say but for example if I
had Tom ran to the IKEA ran to Ikea to
fix his bicycle even though it's bad
idea but you would still have IKEA as an
organization over there so that so
there's different kinds of named
entities you have geopolitical units you
have people you have companies you have
for example you have also places like
you have countries which would be you
know like Amsterdam Netherlands and so
on and so forth but you'd also have
things like mountains and
so like the Carpathian Mountains for the
Carpathian Basin would be a different
entity so you have different kinds of
entities that you can capture over here
in use again it's if any if you're
connected to the Internet I would really
recommend just googling spacy NER tags
to look at the entire list of it I
cannot bring it up right now but in this
case tom is a person so he's tagged as a
person just one thing to point out for
here we did for token incent
and then we went through every single
token what spacy also does is it also
just picks up your entities yeah so in
that case you'd go to for nth incent dot
NS which means for entity and sentences
entities sentence so Tom's the only
entity in the sentence so you'd only
have Tom and person next to it now
pardon me the other cool thing which
Spacey does and this is really neat
because they have this with Jupiter
notebooks they have a nice interactive
way to look at your named entities which
is called display see here it's uh not
so pretty because it's only again one
entity but I threw it's a lot prettier
of there's a lot of entities so uh if
you could like write up a sentence a lot
of entities you can try it out yourself
you know what I'll just do it myself I
should stop okay okay Tom went to Ikea
to get some of those delicious Swedish
meatballs yeah
is there a spelling mistake there
country we see okay either way Stacey
should catch this so um in this
particular case yeah there you go do
they mess up oh they did so it so
perfect so don't you know what exactly
goes on yeah so you catch these entities
and you can display these entities in a
pretty way if you want to you can also
go to the website this place here and
check it out they have a web app but
this is just a way they hook it up with
their Jupiter notebooks
so now dependency parsing which is the
last part so dependency parsing is a
technique in computational linguistics
where you can find out the structure
of your sentence I'll look at the
dependencies each word has with others
that's why it's called dependency
parsing you're gonna get a good example
once I print these things this is not so
these two are not as useful right now
but when you see this it's a bit more
useful so what's happening over here is
normally in dependency parsing the root
word is the word so here went is the
verb and the entire sentence so Tom so
you'd have to study linguistics here to
make more particular sense out of this
particular example but it tells you
normally you have the subject and the
object in sentences and it breaks your
sentence up into your subject and object
and it look it kind of tells you how
different words are related to each
other in a sentence over here now in my
in my opinion my work so far with Spacey
you don't these are not super useful I
prefer I mean it depends on exam what
kind of relations you're actually
looking for between the words for
example if you're looking at you know
again which were who is the subject and
who's the most common subject in these
cases are certain ways to find this out
so Spacey has again on space sees
dependency parsing documentation they go
into more details about the more
practical applications of dependency
parsing but I'm going to give you one
example whatever when I when you talk
about dependencies in this particular
case it's linguistic dependencies but
Spacey also gives you the ability to
create your own dependencies for example
if you want to if you want to consider a
dependency as how you describe something
or like an adjective like for example in
terms of how close it is to something in
proximity like near and far you can
create dependencies by giving examples
of the shop as close to the station and
then close and station you train Spacey
telling telling Spacey that the word
here close means the shop is close to
station you can actually create
dependencies for Spacey to learn and
then use this new dependency scheme for
the rest of your tasks on the website
you can actually odds but this is quite
a big section because they use deep
learning to train these dependencies but
if these kind of things are interesting
for you I'd really recommend checking it
out but as for the vanilla stuff this is
so pretty neat right
but yes so now this is just to give you
an exist whatever has happened here with
the sentence has also happened with Doc
the entire massive corpus this one
forget the Australian newspaper articles
we were talking about before so this is
an example of what Spacey does when we
ran our sentence or document to the
Spacey processing pipeline we normally
had access like I said before at all or
stop words and all the limit I limit
izing and things like this we also have
access to this these kind of neat stuff
but we're gonna this is just like a
small detour to give you an taste of
what you can do it Spacey what we're
actually gonna be using Spacey for is
for cleaning our text so let's look at
this do I need to zoom in for you folks
as well is this okay it's okay
okay so we're gonna now be we're gonna
now create our corpus a corpus is just a
just word today like in natural language
processing it's a word we use to
describe our collection of documents
yeah so most like Jenson for example and
even psychical and it does not accept
just words I mean obviously computers
can't make sense of words what we need
to give them is numbers to represent
these words so there's different ways we
can do this a popular ways bag of words
where we pretty much just count how many
times a particular word appears in a
document you create a diction first you
create a dictionary which maps every
single word to an ID and then you read
your document you see how many times
that IDs occurred in the document which
means how many times that words appeared
in that document and then you just add
that up so it's like a bag of words this
is one popular way another popular way
is tf-idf it stands for term frequency
inverse document frequency it just term
frequency means the number of times that
term the prisoner document in words
document frequency is how is it
distributed among all the other
documents so these are just different
ways for the computer to better
understand what words are in our
documents yeah so we have to first
create this is an extremely extremely
important part of text processing
creating a corpus and cleaning our text
so this is how we're gonna be doing it
in this particular cell now this is
extreme close really fast nice so wait
this is really really important let's
first look at what exactly texts looks
like text is a list of lists
yeah and it's a list of lists
each so the massive list I mean the
outer the outer list is your entire
corpus and each individual list inside
is your individual document I mentioned
before there are 300 documents so the
length of texts which we can quickly
what if I should be 300 please be 300 of
course it had to be $2.99 but you get
the point I mean it's so text contains
all our each of each of our documents
now how did we go from here to here
let's look at this a little more detail
so I did 4w in doc doc is my entire
document which is processed by spaces
let's not forget that and W is each
single token or word so I first look at
this if it's not a newline because if
you if I go back and look at my document
I can see that every new lines the end
of one particular article yes so I'd
want to kind of have a different list
for every article so I want to make sure
it's not a newline if it's not a stop
word so a stop is the is the attribute
each tells us if it's a stopper or not
then if it's not punctuation and if it's
not a number then I want to use this
word yes
species given me all of this information
in one swoop along with the whole parts
of speech tagging a neon and everything
so we had all this information and now
what I'm going to do is attend append
dilemma to the articles so this is the
question you asked me about the space he
also have things like the lemma ties
form of the word and the answer is yes
it does now what exactly are a limiter
is what exactly is limitation for
example in topic models in particular
this is interesting because say we have
say said saying and says these are four
different words but it's not really
important if what it's more useful for
us to know what this word implies which
is the word group would say rather than
having these four individual words for
example imagine we had a final topic or
document we just had say said says for
example so on and so forth this is not
useful information to me it's more
useful if I just have the root word so a
way to find out this root word is a
limit ization there's another way called
this another method called stemming
which will not be using these are just
different ways to go about doing it
limit izing so ulema is your basic
the root form of the word so in this
particular case I only want to add the
root word I don't care about is this
clear do you understand why this I want
to do this and so on so forth it's also
let me make it regular it's very very
neat that Spacey does this first I
cannot stress this enough we're doing in
this six in this tiny loop over here we
are literally building our corpus which
should take a lot more time with an ltk
or doing things on our own yeah Spacey's
making us do things really really fast
over here and after that since when I
see a new line I know it's a new
document so I make my list empty again I
append that article to my massive corpus
and I go on so these two cells are
actually extremely extremely important
they're probably your biggest takeaways
from this don't be disappointed by that
but it's I'm not not not kidding though
it's really really important making your
corpus is an extremely important part of
text analysis and making your corpus
like this is also extremely extremely
important so is that clear is everyone
on board with me up to now awesome okay
so I'm gonna now I'll use so I'm gonna
just now describe a few things you're
gonna use the term or Jennsen specific
we're going to be using our first gen
sim module which is by Graham diagrams
are collocations collocations or
diagrams
they're really neat natural image
processing trick so these work on the
idea that sometimes when some words
appear in the context of other words
they might make more sense if they
appear together I think I've give an
example of the word New York over here
so for example if we see in our in our
body of text that the words in you and
York are appearing often enough for us
to take it seriously it's probably more
useful for us to consider it as New York
instead of new and York yeah so what by
Graham's collocations our words appear
around each other and we just do this in
a probabilistic manner we just look at
how often words appear around each other
and we try and predict if this word is
more useful as one word or not another
example which you'll see again kind of
spoilers but in the topic modeling is
synthesis in 2000 and 2001 Osama bin
Laden is really
irrelevant and so is al-qaeda so you'll
see that when I first ran my topic model
I saw a topic model which is kind of
like a terrorist topic and it had like
al-qaeda Osama bin Laden and so on and
so forth again this is like early 2000
so uh but al-qaeda Osama bin Laden were
all different words and I'm like wait a
second this is not really cool now is it
so I ran these so I looked at my results
when I went back I'm like oh let me use
my grams now and I ran by grams and
after and by grams my results actually
had al-qaeda's one word and so on and so
forth which kind of saves up a word for
me you see so it's a really really neat
trick which is which I would recommend
using if you want to do this kind of
analysis so and by the way you can also
make trigrams like again because the
sama bin ladin is three words if you
want to make a trigram you just run a
bigram and then run another diagram on
top of that it's not really creative but
it's that's how Jenson does it and
that's it so what I'm doing text is
equal to by a gram of line for line in
text I'm recreating my original corpus
but now with diagrams yeah is this clear
so now let's look at texts of ten to see
if we find any diagrams come on by
Graham's should test this before I Oh
awesome new South so you can see New
South Wales was is one particular case
in this corpus a New South Wales I think
it's a state in Australia though I
reckon it is so which is why it's caught
up maybe there's something else which
also comes up blue mountains which is
probably interesting maybe it's an in
the mountains nearby so you can see how
by grams has caught words now in the
example of blue mountains it must the
reason it's called blue mountains is
because it's actually read the entire
corpus enough times for it to think that
okay blue mountains has come often
enough together for us to consider it as
one word it would not consider it as one
for example if you use these same by
gamma a different corpus it would
probably not concatenate green mountains
because it's not seen green mountains
it's seen blue mountains so it's gonna
do this yeah okay so now we're gonna
actually create a final corpus I talked
to earlier about yeah
I'm not adding any I'm not using any
named entities information but why
exactly do you think would be useful
here
oh no no no so when I'm when I'm
creating my diagrams I'm just using a
basic conditional probability trying to
figure out what are the odds of this
word appearing around this word I'm not
using any prior information if it's a
political entity though I'm assuming for
example if you because you if you were
training a neural network this might be
useful information but in this
particular case we can just go ahead
with this but also just note the named
entities that you mentioned we are done
by Spacey and this is Jensen which are
different packages so Jensen only uses
just basic probably difficult stuff does
not use any other information so now I
mentioned before that computers don't
understand words they only understand
numbers so now we're going to be first
creating a dictionary a dictionary is
just mapping every word to an ID so okay
so now my corpus I do dictionary dot doc
to bow dr. Bower stands for document to
bag of words and now I have my bag of
words what does this look like this is
the hundred document so it's basically
said word ID number fourteen I'm not
sure which what that is but it doesn't
really matter now it appears three times
in this document and so on and so forth
so if you even if you really want to
know what it is just it's feel kind of
guilty if I don't okay yes so dictionary
of fourteen is the word in okay that's
boring but the word in the word in comes
in that particular document three times
so that's what bag of words is you see
it basically counts how many times the
particular words appearing in the
document and goes on building it stuff
like that so here we go so at the end of
corpus were actually done with our
pre-processing this is the pre this is a
kind of this is the most straightforward
pre-processing which is normally done in
text processing what we did was we got
rid of numbers we got rid of punctuation
we got rid of stop words we added a
limit I store the base
form of the word and this is all we did
we can get fun we can you know do more
creative things with this if you really
want to but it also depends on looking
at the results and saying oh this looks
bad so I should probably process my text
better and then you go on you go back
and then you look at it again then you
run the whole thing again but this is
the pre-processing which we're going to
be doing and we've set up our corpus and
you'll use by grams and now we're gonna
do our first machine learning part which
is our topic modeling so I'm gonna first
briefly explain what topic models are
okay exam okay for example let's say you
have a bunch of newspaper articles yeah
you worked for newspaper company have a
bunch of newspaper articles completely
unstructured text you have no labels no
categories no dates nothing you just
have 500 just make up numbers 500
thousand articles from the last 20 years
and you just know when your boss tells
you organize this [ __ ] for me and you
have no idea what you want to do so this
is where a topic modeling is
particularly useful it's because it
helps us do an unsupervised modeling of
your documents what does this mean this
means we have no labels and no tags
we're working with we're just going to
ask algorithm to try and figure out what
these topics what what these documents
are about now I gave you an example of
newspaper articles so what kind of
topics will we be dealing with maybe
politics sport weather and finance maybe
for example so we expect these kind of
topics should show up but there could be
more there could be less so intuitively
depending on the size of your corpus you
say 10 topics yeah so you think there's
going to be 10 topics and this and you
want to kind of see with the broad
overview what kind of 10 topics are here
in my corpus so what what's going on
under the hood like I'm gonna do a
really like hand-wavy mathematics over
here is it assumes a distribution over
so what examined astre bution here I'm
talking about a probabilistic
distribution over each document so what
it says is that each document is made
from a bunch of topics and each topic is
made from a bunch of words so for
example your sports
topic might have words like football
basketball
Iraq's Europa League champions league
and so on and so forth now the topic the
computer doesn't know that the topic is
called the sports topic you see it's
just gonna say that this topic ID number
three has these words appearing in
really high probability which is why we
call it a probability distribution so
it's gonna say topic ID number four of
these words and these high probabilities
then you can have another topic say the
sports say the already soft were
supposed to weather topic and the other
topic since Amsterdam it's gonna have
rain rain and more rain but no so you
get you get the point that you get the
gist you're gonna have different topics
with different words appearing in
different probabilities the computer
doesn't know what this topic is mark
test we're gonna have to model name
these topics ourselves but you're gonna
find so many words later this topic
we're gonna be able to do this after and
you're gonna have in each topic you're
not gonna have different words appearing
with different probabilities so you can
have 45% of the chance of the word euro
poly Europa is going to appear in
football and so on and so forth and
you're gonna later have documents which
are made out of topics so it's gonna
probably say the first 30 documents are
80 percent football are and so on and so
forth if for example in some bizarre
turn of events Hillary Clinton is
playing football and really rainy
Stadium somewhere you're gonna have 30
percent politics 30 percent sports 30
percent so whether you see so each
document is made out of a bunch of
topics each topic is made out of a bunch
of words
you
what we're going to be doing now is for
and generally I mean creating your topic
model is super easy we've imported LD a
model from Jensen Jensen is the library
which will be using for topic modeling
which is arguably the best topic
modeling library out there right now
those scikit-learn also has topic
modeling but Jensen is kind of made for
text so deal to the quirks of text a
little bit a little bit better so here
we go our only parameters which are
passing is the corpus which is what we
created you saw the numbers the bag of
words the number of topics on Lda we
need to mention how many topics we
expect as for finding out the right
number of topics really it's impossible
to say for sure what number of topics
are gonna expect to find depends you're
gonna have to run a bunch of tests and
look at I'm gonna just a link over here
which I've mentioned I think I mention
it but yeah in the same so in the same
directory you're gonna have my other
topic modeling tutorial which is a
tutorial only for topic modeling so if
you want to get more into for example
are choosing your number of topics
there's a bunch of different topic
models choosing which topic model you
want and stuff like that you can check
out that different tutorial but now I'm
just going to show you really quickly LD
a model so it's training over there and
it's done and I'm gonna show you topics
uh-oh so you can see over here that the
word though and pron which I'm not sure
what it is is coming up very often in
all of these which means that it's a
stop word which is not properly caught
so I would have had to go back and make
sure I get rid of the but I'm not gonna
do that right now I want to finish the
tutorial but this is a good example of
not we're not cleaning your data can
lead to nonsense results I did not plan
this but it's worked out well you can
still kind of see the topics I suppose
for example over here top of three says
attack group Palestinian both things
haven't changed things are still
miserable but yeah you can see that in
this particular example this is kind of
a topic to do with the Middle East then
you have government Australia Australian
Afghanistan so again these are not very
good topics let's bother some this so in
this particular example this means I
probably want to go back to my original
original corpus pick up the words which
I don't like for example I don't pran
might be something which speak
Rona Bush doesn't make some sense so I'd
want to get rid of duh prong maybe des
is not particularly important
information to me so I get rid of the
word de add that to my stop words listen
and I come back and then I look at these
results again so when you're looking at
topic models if you're not satisfied and
you're rarely satisfied with your first
round of results which you get you're
supposed to go back pick out the right
stop words you want I got Rick get rid
of and you can see I've only the earlier
model I did it got trained in around
three or three or four seconds it means
that it didn't run through multiple
rounds it was just one pass you can
change this as well if you want a more
fine-tuned topic model I'm not going to
be going through this particular part
right now because I have a lot more to
show you but again in the same directory
there's another topic modeling library a
topic modeling tutorial which I've
written which has the same exact corpus
with a lot nicer looking results so
since we're doing this right now live
and the stop words aren't cleaned so
well it looks a bit messy but this still
gives you an idea of what a topic looks
like you can see over there that 0.10 of
zero says that the word though has a
point that's the probability of the word
the appearing in topic zero normally
that word should not be though it should
be something which makes more sense but
you get the gist of it correct about
prong I'm honestly not sure I think Tron
was something Spacey spat out and I
think it's just a word so what
for example if I'd want to get rid of
this just before in my corpus over here
I'd be looking at this and looking at so
I can see that all still exists over
here at and yeah so you can see it's not
been cleaned exactly the way I want to
because these words are not added to my
stop word list in which case I'd want to
go back and do it just to give you an
example of what the results might look
like is their topic modeling this is my
topic modeling tutorial which I talked
about before I just want to give you an
example of what a nicer topic modeling
come on scroll for me
pardon me yeah so do these look better I
cannot see oh yeah this stuff doesn't it
so this is a the same corpus but China
and a different whole notebook so this
is probably an example of better looking
topics I hope kind of but this is again
so you get the idea of how topics work
so I'm gonna go back to the text
analysis okay so this is topic modeling
so we saw over here topics as for your
question about dough and prawn it's not
supposed to be there we're gonna want to
get rid of it in our text before we
actually do it so this is one part so
this is one example of the kind of
things you can do using Jensen Jensen
has a bunch of other really cool stuff
one of my favorite text analysis
techniques is word to work a lot of
people are heard word to records yeah
yes yes yeah good good good questions
anything yeah yeah of course fair enough
so did everyone get that question it was
basically was this is doesn't look way
useful how do I make this useful kind of
yeah okay so yeah so again I'd like to
really mention that in this particular
case we need to go back and get rid of
the example the word though would you
say first want to get rid of your stop
words so once you get rid of your stop
words and maybe you can run this with
two passes instead of just one pass or a
50 if you have time to spare so once you
do that I'm gonna give the energy of the
newspaper example for example the
newspaper articles for example you once
you have your topics what you can
possibly do with it is apart from the
idea that say you know you didn't know
what was in the league the corpus we
were talking about right you had no idea
which is in there I mean I told you
folks that the lis corpus has
Australian newspaper articles from the
years 2000 2001 now if I didn't tell you
that and I told you we're just analyzing
a corpus and then I showed you these
results even though it's a really really
bad topic model you still know that this
is a topic this corpus probably contains
information about Australia the
government things going on in the Middle
East so it's maybe Australian news you
know so it's given you a good overview
of what's actually inside my entire
corpus say all my documents without
having to even read a single document
and this is with a bad topic model
imagine the wonders you could do with a
good topic model so the other topic
modeling tutorial which you again like
I've said seen on this corpus I talked
about three other different kinds of
topic models topic model currents
calculation which is trying to find out
the most coherent or meaningful topic
model so I've talked about measures for
finding out so coherency is how human
interpretability pact model is so you
always choose and fine-tune your topic
model and you can so how it's useful
usually in just explaining to people
what's in my documents that's that's
probably the most popular way because
mind II this is completely unstructured
unlabeled I have no clue what I'm
dealing with and suddenly I have so much
information what you can also do now is
if you pick up every document X I can
show you right now making you so I can't
see the top of my
pardon me okay so if I want so this is
to show you the topics if I want to see
what's the break up of for example this
what I did over here was I passed Corpus
9 I mean corpus of 9 years my tenth
document to the LDA model and now what
I've gotten returned is what is the so
in this particular case topic z-corp
article number 10 is composed 98% of
topic 0 so you can also now find out
what is the percentage of each topic in
all of my articles maybe this example is
not telling us so much so I don't know
ok this is kind of more interesting so
article number 89 is 25% topic 5 and 73%
topic 7 you see so this is the other
kind of information and which we which
we get we can actually every single one
of our documents we can classify kind of
we can't really classify because it's
not a 0 one thing over here but we can
get an idea what it's made out of it's 7
via person this 22% this this can later
if you want to cluster this is a way we
can help in clustering as well so
there's a bunch of things we can do with
topic models in general you can also
find out what is the topic of every
single word in your document and you can
like color the words in your document to
find out if it's a mix so again there's
a lot of different the what do you have
to understand is topics made our words
documents made out of topics and words
words in each topic document belong to a
topic if you can kind of see where
things are related using this
information we can do a lot of fun stuff
with our topic models so it's more of a
data exploratory kind of thing you know
which is why you don't have things like
accuracy you cannot test how well the
topic model is like for example this
topic model could make a lot of sense to
someone but not for me so you'd want to
retrain it and fine-tune it normally
it's used for another really popular
example is in science I mean in general
I can research researchers like to find
out what other researchers are doing
research about so you used topic
modeling on all the papers written in
computer science in last 120 years
to see what people are talking about
kind of arrange articles you can use it
to browse and find things so in general
it's more for the expert I don't know
what's going on so I kind of want to
have a look and then if you want to get
funky and do a little more stuff you can
do that too but again I give more
examples of things you can do in my
other tutorial so I really recommend
checking it out of this interests here
yeah yeah you can feed them so seeding I
mean like seeding is using a lot of
things I mean for like so the idea of
seeding something is to kind of force or
push you push sure Al Gore than the
right direction so Jennsen again has
ways to do this in your agency of look
of the documentation for seeding your
topic model but you can say that you
expect these topics to appear to kind of
give it a head start and look for these
topics okay for example it's just called
seeding actually seeding your topic
model yeah yeah it's pretty neat yeah
and like gents and so Jensen is I would
really recommend checking out Jensen
they're really really exhaustive suite
of topic models I'm a big fan of their
work so and they're really easy to
contribute to great open source teams so
if for example you find out the
seedlings not up to the standard of what
you'd like to see put up an issue and
you could actually ask get someone to
work on that as soon as possible as well
so if this interests you just yeah but
you can feed your topic models yes I saw
another hand going up I'm sorry yes yeah
so the rule of thumb is there is no
there is no rule of thumb really but
what you can do for example is you look
at the size of your corpus if there's
100 documents maybe and you expect a
certain number of topics you would start
with that number now this is again
really hand wavy if you want a
particular way to choose your number of
topics there is a method called topic
coherence the topic Arendt just tells
you how much how much human sense do
these topics make so then what you do is
you train ten topic models on the same
corpus with ten 20 30 40 50 60 so how
many other topics you want you train all
these models then you check the topic of
urns for each of these ten models and
then you choose the number of topics
with the highest number so this is a
quantitative way to figure out topic
coherence honestly when I'm doing it I
just wing it I'm like you know what
seven topics sounds good and then I just
do BAM and it usually works out kind of
yeah
yeah so so in this particular case
things like sentiment or car like
semantics or you know like intelligent
information is not what you're going to
be getting for example you're not gonna
find out doing sentiment analysis a
topic modeling which is kind of what
you're talking about like McLean not
clean I mean sentiment you mean you get
it just so this is not something which
is very useful because topic modeling
only gives you words one possible
solution when you're doing your by grams
if not clean pick comes up often enough
not clean or actually picked up as one
by gram so in this case if you expect
not clean to appear in your set in your
corpus kind of force it to have not
clean as one word fair enough so in this
case you don't get semantic information
caught because you can see the results
it listed it's literally just picking up
the words so but then again your topic
will not be a dirty or clean topic your
topic will be a towel topic and this
towel topic would have clean and dirty
so you see it's not the purpose of what
you want to do a topic modeling if if
you want to find out the sentiment of
the reviews I mean this that's a whole
other ballgame we are sentiment analysis
and that's a completely different way
you want to approach things in that case
we're a semantic starts becoming more
important you'd use things like word to
AK which is a really popular machine
learning algorithm which I might talk
about it onif at the time but you'd use
other techniques which involve meaning
more in this case we're not really
looking at meaning we're just looking at
a broad overview of our text yeah any
other questions yeah it's still there
okay good I'm sorry
okay could you do me a favor could you
just open an issue on the same
repository the personal my repository
with this notebooks stating the issue so
that what I'm gonna do is once I go back
or tomorrow during the conference I can
play around with it and then update it
make the changes on the github
repository so tomorrow you and you can
actually log on look at my github
repository you can see the correct
outputs so just open an issue with the
exact but that should not be there just
to clarify yeah no way okay okay cool
just again like the more issues you
folks open up the better so I can have
more examples to look at and then I can
get this fixed because I think I've seen
this before and my old tutorials doesn't
don't have this problem so just whatever
issues you have with any particular
lines of code you can see by the way
just another point which I forgot to
mention the notebook I'm running right
now it's called text analysis tutorial
on run and then I'm running it I have an
already run version of the exact same
notebook on the repository as well if
you want to see the results so you can
compare but if there's a mistake I'm
gonna have to rerun both notebooks but
thanks for pointing that out is there
anything else okay so now we're done
with Jensen for now some of just like to
talk about the other things that Jensen
has to offer
apart from topic modeling it has
something called dynamic topic modeling
which includes time stamps as well so
you can find out evolution of topics
over time it has summarization so it has
ways to summarize your text it looks for
sentences in your articles which have
the most information and it can create
summaries of synoptic synopsises and
things like that it can do pardon me it
can do what to whack word to AK or I
really like what 2x I'm just gonna give
you a small example if you folks have
been around various data science meetups
you've heard were to come off and I mean
just use anyone not know what rhetoric
is Oh awesome okay cool so we're to act
so like the name suggests it stands for
word - wetter so what it does is it
basically creates a vector
a representation of a word do you know
what a vector is yeah so when you when
we were creating a vector representation
of a word we'd want to try and have this
vector try to best capture the semantic
meaning of the image capture the
understanding of the word so I'll give
you an example normally if you're
representing the word this is the most
popular example euston were to act which
is it's done by these folks at Google
and there is really fun paper on in 2013
so you can actually see the entire
research paper which is a really
well-written paper and the example they
give is they calculate so vector like I
said is basically a mathematical
representation of a word now if this
mathematical representation of a word
can also translate the meaning of the
word that would be really neat and
that's what work to egg does where 2ik
understands the meaning of words and
tries to you know show that in a
mathematical way for example they did
the word vector of king - man plus woman
so again just to make this clear King -
man plus woman any guesses what that
would be I mean come on someone you know
queen Lawrence Queen yes thank you so
King - man plus woman is queen I mean
even as human beings and we think of
this intuitively yeah we get an idea of
royalty take out the man add the woman
you get queen now the incredible thing
was word to a call so actually did this
it actually if you did the word vector
of King - the word vector of man plus
the word vector of woman the word vector
which we got was closest to the word
lecture of Queen which is really really
neat so this is an entire there's a lot
of different these are called word
embeddings because it captures semantic
understanding of words now there's a lot
of different kinds of word embeddings
and Jensen has around four or five of
these fast text I think poincare
embeddings and the word to work of
course different kinds of word
embeddings dense them also has these so
I really recommend checking Jensen out
if you're interested in text analysis in
general topic modeling and word
embeddings tend to be its speciality
what we're moving on to now is text
classification we're going to be using
psychic learn because psychic learn has
I mean Jensen doesn't have a clustering
or classification algorithms but
scikit-learn does and scikit-learn has a
pretty decent text processing pipeline
as well so this is a really really super
vanilla example I'm not even kidding but
it's just to kind of give you an example
of the you know the work the workflow of
and you're dealing with clustering or
classification in this particular
example what we're going to be doing is
we're gonna again we're not going to be
using the leaked corpus data the lis
background data set anymore because that
was unlabeled it remember that's how I
use it for topic modeling it had no
additional information and we didn't
have any idea what kind of classes are
found in that corpus in this corpus
however just called a twenty ng corpus
or the twenty newsgroup corpus there's
20 different categories in our corpus so
we're gonna be doing an example of
classification where we're gonna pick up
a document and then classify it in only
four not twenty because I just want to
show you what it looks like on the four
ones which are going to be using it or
eight of them miscellaneous graphics in
space these are the four top categories
which are on the psychotron website
which is why I chose these kind of lazy
I know I'm sorry but this is taken like
I said to give you an example of the
pipeline or the workflow we'll be using
when we're dealing with clustering and
classification the difference between
clustering and classification is in
classification we know our labels we
have a labels and we want to put our
documents into these labels we're sure
it's going to be in one of these labels
in clustering we don't really know what
the labels are even if we do we just
want to kind of generally put it
somewhere in similar clusters
classification we're sure that it
belongs to this or this or this or the
other class here for classes like the
ones you see over there you can see the
four categories over there and let's
start our imports so over here fetch
twenty newsgroups
fetches our data set truncated SVD
tf-idf hashing and all of these over
here are used to pre-process our text
data I'm going to give a little more
information about that and it's the same
with our pipelines so let's see we want
to run this over here and I'm going to
explain what's going on
data train fetch
20 news groups again as you can see this
kind of self-explanatory if you're not
understanding any particular line over
here please stop me but here we're just
picking up our training data and so the
thing about text processing is it's
generally what we consider a high
dimensional problem a high dimensional
problem is a problem where there's a lot
of features now what exactly are
features features or any kind of
information which we use to make a
classification or make a decision here
our features are our words yeah because
we're going to be using words which are
in the document to make decisions of
which class does this document belong in
is that clear now assuming that in these
four classes which I picked up which are
these four categories over here there
could be ten thousand words or twenty
thousand words or I'm not sure about the
exact size vocabulary but either way
those are a lot of features and we don't
want to be using all of these features
or making a decision it just takes more
time and it's not the best way to do
things so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna kind of shrink or reduce the
dimensions of our data the way we do
this is here you see what Reiser is
equal to tf-idf vectorizer what I
mentioned before is the last time we use
bag-of-words remember where we've kind
of put we built these backwards using
Jennsen now we're gonna use tf-idf which
is just another way to represent these
words and after that we're gonna so then
we do what has a fit transform data
train door data which basically means
over here now we have our tf-idf data
after tf-idf we're going to be using SVD
which stands for singular value
decomposition and what it does is it's
basically linear algebra and what it
does is it produces dimensions I know
that's a bad it's probably not the
reasoning which you wanted but a little
more I'm trying to see what would make
an interesting way so if you have a
really really massive matrix with all of
your features what kind of smaller
matrix can you construct using these
documents which represent these words in
the best possible way using linear
algebra again I know again that sounds
very hand wavy if you're interested
about the actual mathematics I'd
recommend googling it but as of now what
we're going to be doing is using
truncated SVD here we say number of
components is 5 which means we're going
to reduce our
aside from how many ever number of
features it was initially - just five
components or five features yes and
these are just the steps you do to
create this pipeline and normalize our
data this is this what we're going to be
doing to get our data ready we're going
to be doing the exact same thing with
our testing data over here and now let's
do the actual classifying so the first
class fare are going to be using is the
naive base is the name basis it is the
Gaussian on your base so the naive Bayes
classifier what it is pretty much does
is it uses a Bayesian probability which
means that it's going to check what are
the odds for example in living example
of classifies using spam that's an easy
example you want to classify your
textual data into spam and not spam yeah
so it's likely that certain documents
are mostly are going to contain words
which are most liked or gonna put it
more likely to be in spam for example
winner or enlargement or words if they
appear in your mail they're likely going
to be spam so this means that if these
words appear in our documents higher
probability this belongs to spam so it's
just based on conditional probability
this is what naive based us and it's
super easy to use it we're gonna G and B
is equal to Gaussian are you both just a
Gaussian version of a Navy base
algorithm and why pred okay so now that
this is done so wipe red now what you
lose gene b dot fit train X&Y so what
you're doing is you're training your
classifier which is when i you based
classifier with your training data which
is your X and your Y your X are your
documents and your Y is which class it
belongs in so this is the information
you're giving your classifier all my
documents and which class do these
documents belong in it then creates
these probabilities which I talked about
these conditional probabilities and then
we predict with our test data so in just
one line of code we have wipe so wipe
red and B now has every single class of
every document in our testing so for
example
damnit I want to create a new yeah so
let's look at so this tells us that in X
test the first document belongs in
category 0 then 3 and so on and so forth
so what's going on right now is wipe
read and B contains after we fit our G
and B model using our training data we
then predicted on our testing data the
results are stored in wipe red and these
are the classes of our documents is this
extremely clear to everyone here yeah
awesome so now we're going to move on to
another kind of classifier it's the SVM
classifier which is a support vector
machine it's a bit more difficult to
explain this conceptually but what's up
support vector machines does is normally
if you have a lot of data we try to draw
a line to classifier data into two
different categories an SVM kind of uses
kernels to move to a different
prediction space and we try and drop a
plane instead of a line to separate our
classes it's just a different
mathematical way to actually do a
classification again if you want to get
into the nitty gritties of it you can
search up the details but scikit-learn
luckily enough for us is very very well
done and very well written we can use
these classifying objects as black boxes
where we expect it to kind of work if
you want to get into more detail about
which classify is the best that's a
whole different ballgame but I just
wanted to introduce you all to the world
of scikit-learn
and classification using cyclins so is
everyone clear on where so I could learn
and text come in to our whole pipeline
of text analysis any other any questions
regarding this particular section no
cool we're now going to move on to so
this point which you might have seen
throughout this tutorial is a again I'm
not going into a lot of depth into
either topic modeling or computational
linguistics or classify
I'm just giving you an example of the
fun things you can do with text what
I've done is giving you the links to
actually go into more detail if you're
interested in this particular aspect of
text analysis yeah now this is our last
part at least in this tutorial so what
we'll be doing is generating text I
talked earlier about the example of
generating Shakespeare text where we try
and create what make a machine create
this kind of text I'm gonna give you a
little bit of an intuitive example of
how neural networks do this the actual
it's quite complex the way they work
I've put two links over there which I
really really enjoy understanding lsdm
networks and the unreasonable
effectiveness of recurrent neural
networks which are two very very popular
and a lot of fun actually
come on including loads of fun both of
these blog posts they really get into
the details of how these work and give
nice into two examples so if you want to
get more into how these really work you
can read these articles I've linked to
both of them in my directory to give you
a bit of intuitive understand of how
neural networks allow us to generate
text it creates a window and tries to
four so you have a document what it does
is it first reads your entire document a
whole bunch of times and it tries to
predict given this character or or a
word depending on what kind of new
electric it is if it's a character level
or a word level it says based on this
character a word appearing right here
what are the odds what was the most
likely next character appearing
somewhere so given the word for example
the words that pop the quick brown fox
jumped over the lazy dog so in that
particular example if you if you keep
telling a neural network this sentence
it's just going to say given the quick
brown fox it's going to predict the word
jump next because it's just seen that so
many times now you go on and train this
over a really really massive corpus it
starts to learn or pick up or understand
what kind of words do I need to start
predicting so that it mimics the
original
distribution the best possible way so
what's going to happen is soon you're
gonna have a neural network which is
going to be saying things we're going to
start talking for example it's a really
fun example where there's a trump tweet
generator where it kind of just
generates tweets which it learns the way
Trump says when he says sad or big news
or fake news it kind of it can predict
that in fact Winston's the PI data
amsterdam organizer I suppose you all
have met has a really nice experiment
where he generates Pokemon names as well
I really enjoy that talk yeah so this is
an example of using neural networks to
generate text you can actually sort it
tries to learn is what are the odds of
this particular style of language
appearing based on the context now again
this is again super hand wavy
so if you want to find out more about
how this is done check the links out as
for what we're going to be using to do
this actually generate text as Kearse
Kiera's is a really high level
neural networks library which means that
there are other libraries like
tensorflow and Tiano
which allow you to actually construct
your neural networks from scratch where
you choose what activate activation
functions how many layers how many
networks but if you don't if you
couldn't care enough about the actual
insights of what's going on and you want
to create a neural network and really
less lines of code this is a really
really neat way to do it so i would
really recommend checking out kira
skeeters actually built on tensorflow
and pianos who are actually using these
libraries to build on your own metrics
but Kira's makes the layer of
abstraction one level higher making it
easier for us to use it's also right now
the one of the most popular neural
network creating libraries which we have
out there and for text processing it's
really easy to do things I'd like to
notice note one thing most of the text
here is most of the cells over here are
taken from the Jupiter notebook my good
pal carrot and he's done a similar
tutorial as well where he focuses more
into the details since I've talked about
a lot of things before this I'm not
going to talk so much about the nature
of all of the code over here I'm gonna
of course briefly explain it but I would
highly recommend checking out that
github repository as well
if you're interested about how exactly
why we're writing these lines of code
though I'm still going to go over some
details so
start with their imports so what's going
on over here is another example of how I
told you before of how I mentioned
computers don't understand text the way
we do so we're not gonna have just words
right so we need what this is called one
heart and coding which is kind of saying
zero is if that word exists 1 if that
word doesn't exist so this is just an
example of the kind of input data which
our neural network needs this is our
Kira's model now so it's going to a
little more detail about what's going on
over here
so these are parameters of our neural
network which is things like drop rate
activation and mode which tells us what
kind of characters we want to give our
neural network now it's been found out
for generating text that these
particular parameters are the ones which
make it function for generating text
better if you want these neural networks
to do something else like classification
because you can also classify text with
using neural networks you'd be
generating or constructing your neural
network in a different way with
different architectures different kinds
of layers and different kinds of
parameters the parameters that you'll be
using in this particular set of examples
are just best ones for text generation
so over here our inputs is so based of
course mind you we are not these are
just functions we're gonna actually be
running these functions later but just
to give you an example over here this is
the input shape LST M stands for a long
long short long short term memory and
what it does is again it's it's its
architecture best allows us to capture
the contexts that we need in a
generating text it's not for example we
need to remember what came before and
also what's immediately around it like I
mentioned before this particular blog is
super cool for understanding iOS TM
networks in particular and LST M's are
really useful when we're generating text
now we're going to be creating your
models again I'm aware of the fact this
is really hand wavy and I'm not getting
into details it's because we're running
out of time and I'd rather want to just
give you an intuitive idea of how we're
gonna be generating this but if anyone
if you still want to know what this
particular line does please stop me so
here we'll be using a sequential kind of
model that is the kind of model or the
kind of neural network model which we'll
be using to generate our text and our
model here
it's an LS TM and hidden dimensions and
input shapes are our inputs if depending
on the number of layers again the number
of layers is simply the number the kind
of complexity we'll be having in our
neural network so this is for creating
our model training our model is so here
loss categorical cross entropy is just a
kind of loss what lost means over here
is we want to see how when we want to
see how well our neural network performs
we check the loss loss is the difference
between the real and the expected value
there different ways to calculate loss
and this is what we choose opt is your
optimizer which is just the way you want
the new letter to do it's optimization
there's also something called dropout
rate which helps when we tell our neural
effort to stop focusing or training on
this particular thing to dropout it's to
prevent something called overfitting
overfitting is when we over generalize
for a particular data set and it stops
being general-purpose so again these are
all parameters which are involved in
neural networks I'm sorry for not
getting into the details if this was a
deep learning tutorial I really would
have loved to but in this case I just
want to give you enough context so you
can later go ahead and do this stuff
yourself this is our so until now what
read what we've done is we've just
created our model we've not actually
started the process of text generation
so I'm going to give a little bit of
example a little bit of context or
intuition about how we can generate text
once we create our model or model now
kind of has an intuitive understanding
of given this particular character what
is the most what is the character most
likely each is going to appear next so
we also want to spend you want to start
generating text we want to seed our
model like we talked about seeding
before seeding
means kind of giving it a kick starter a
push and then after that it starts
generating text so over here we have our
seed and we have our start which is
going to be a random start with these
are the loss and the optimizer we talked
about before and here something yes I'm
sorry
yes seeding is definitely different from
training
so what's training is when we are
looking at our text and just figuring
out our probabilities of what are the
odds of the next word appearing yeah
what seeding is is we give a word and
then we're telling our model start so
seeding is kind of the first word we're
giving our model after it's been trained
you see yeah so what's going on over
here is this is our where only we only
want to generate 250 characters for now
mainly because we don't have time and if
this the training process takes quite a
while so this is the way we do it we
first predict our more will you do model
dot prick it basically means what is the
next word which is going to come up then
after that we convert that in redoing NP
dot org max a prediction we're choosing
the highest probability the word with
the highest probability of appearing
next the character and then after that
we are printing this you're going to be
seeing this over here now what data I'm
using over here is the same lis
background corpus which we talked about
before so these are just this is
important information for the neural
network when we are generating text
because you need again our IDs which we
talked about before to recreate our
characters again this is more stuff to
get our data of so again this is just
getting our data in shape making sure
everything's good to go and now we're
gonna actually doing do the heavy
lifting which is creating our model
using the create model method over here
which I kind of walked you folks over
now we're going to be training here
remember we've not doing any seeding yet
over here now this is the part which is
going to take some time so I'm actually
going to use this time too
come up and show you what the results
are supposed to look like so after we're
training our model epoch is just
basically the training section this is
the already run group and it takes a
little more time force actually do the
training over here what's happening is
once we've trained our model we're gonna
start generating our text so you can see
over here that it has been developing
tools to something prison its world
Australia somewhere here it'll be really
nice oil prices okay which means that we
kind of recreated 250 characters of a
newspaper article from the training that
we trained on
now if these this looks lousy it's also
because it took it was a really really
small data source we didn't have much
text which we fed to a neural network
model and we also spent very less time
in doing the actual training if you want
it to be extremely coherent you'd be
training it more and it takes a lot of
time hours or even days to have model
which is generating text which is really
really really human intelligible what I
would again really want you to do and I
cannot recommend this enough is to read
this blog post the unreasonable
effectiveness of recurrent neural
networks which has extremely interesting
examples from our intense trained on
different kinds of data sources and the
results it also has shakes for example
just ends up being quite cool it has and
this is really really fun it has an
entire example trained on the Linux
source code so it's generating source
code with correct braces and indentation
it's mental so I would really recommend
super fun so I would really really
recommend checking out that blog post
what I showed you here you can actually
put in whatever so there's one
particular line over here where I feed
in my data source I had a game of
thrones one but I kind of lost my data
source which would have been fun to show
you folks but so instead of using the
boring in 2001 newspaper corpus but yeah
you can just replace these lines of code
and you now have text generated in the
style of whatever you want the blog post
again has a lot more interesting
examples but as you can see the code is
also fairly straightforward to
understand if you want to make a better
curious model you'd have to go more into
imitation of Kiryas and look at all the
examples but there you go these lines of
code are nice let's see if our models
been trained any wagers okay it has and
now we're gonna come on don't do this to
me there we go yeah so Afghanistan
something yes so you have a incinerator
that's kind of harsh okay so yeah so
this is the text generated in the by the
neural network which was trained while
we were talking that took an extremely
that barely took any time which is
really neat now if this happened in
around a minute you can only imagine
with a much larger corpus and with more
concentrated training efforts that we're
going to be seeing a lot more
sophisticated kind of outputs so yeah
that brings us to the end of this
tutorial we talked about a lot a lot of
different things and that was the
purpose of this it was not to go into
depth behind any one particular kind of
text analysis technique but to rather
explore the giant I mean the the scope
there's just so much if we do a quick
recap we started out about why I know
Tek is horrible sorry you know it's
recorded oops
so we talked about why you shouldn't use
an OT k and then we talked about why you
should use Spacey because it does a
whole bunch of things in one shot then
we talked about different ways we get
our text ready by making diagrams in New
York and so on and so forth we talked
about dictionaries and corpuses and
basically entire training part we talked
about computational linguistics which is
about parts of speech tagging NER
dependency parsing which is again what
Spacey does then we moved on to topic
models and how we can find an overall
view of our text using topic models
after that we talked about text
classification using scikit-learn and
how we can set up our data and how
classification works when we know our
classes before we start our experiment
and then after that we did deep learning
where we're using neural networks to
generate text I also briefly talked
about word to act though I didn't
actually show you any work of examples
it's actually really really easy coding
Jennsen as well so I hope you're all
impressed enough with text analysis and
Python this is all
most of this is native Python and all of
these libraries are really nice
communities really friendly people and I
would really recommend checking these
libraries out checking out text analysis
in general also since I'm here a little
bit of publicity I've written a book on
text analysis I like to Thursdays two
weeks ago and it's gonna be out it's
published by Packt publishing house
it'll be on Amazon and I think I'm gonna
add the link to this repository so you
can find it later the book pretty much
covers all the things I talked about and
more of course with a lot of details and
Jupiter notebooks and text examples so
yeah so you can buy my book if you like
text analysis and this or anything else
or questions and I'm here at Amsterdam
for PI data today and tomorrow and day
after as well so I'd love to hear your
questions and raise your issues on the
github repository if there's any
problems with the code I will do my best
to look look at it and push the update
so that you can have the final working
code as well I would have liked all of
you to actually run the notebooks
yourself that's what I normally like to
do in these tutorials but couldn't
happen this time but I hope you all
still had fun thank you for having me
[Applause]